sigmund freud
what do you make of the ideas that he
had so you mentioned
taking the unconscious the subconscious
seriously
that's like step one like that there
could be worlds we do not have direct
access for we
probe at them
through conversation or
um is it too simplistic to call
psychoanalysis conversation that's not
too simplistic but that's right and i
think that was valuable where where
freud ended up breaking from some of his
contemporaries he was very focused on
this unconscious as being so tightly
linked to libido and and really he
from his perspective you couldn't really
separate the operation of the
unconscious mind from these aspects of
the libidinous aspects and that was one
reason
you know sex sexual sexually related uh
you know drives
carl jung who was his you know
uh you know contemporary that's one
factor that led to them separating was
you know carl jung felt there was a lot
more
to the unconscious than than this
libidinous aspect of it and he saw it as
a much more
complete uh
uh alternate representation of the the
conscious self one that maybe reflected
a whole range of different
motivations and and desires
um
and
to to properly treat it one had to
consider all of them rather than the
ones that destroyed us
thank you
thank you for the high level of uh of
images that sergey is pulling out for
people who are just listening he pulled
up a
as a quote from uh segment four it's a
meme your mom quote uh freud uh so the
the shadow the carl jung's shadow
encompasses
everything not just the desire to have
sex with your mother
or sex period that's right that's right
if you look at those two folks
on mass i mean there's a kind of
it's almost like a technique for
philosophical exploration
of human mind human motivations
so it's not even like necessarily
it also doubles as a methodology for
helping people but it's almost like a
uh it's a kind of
philosophical method
right
this is the fascinating thing about
about psychoanalysis and and
it even though it's it's i would say
mostly not considered a treatment today
it persists for a couple reasons one is
it it's it's thought that it gives
people some insight
but
second there's been a huge influence on
on literature on philosophy on art
and the the opening up of discussion
about what was
below our conscious mind was uh so so
fertile and in the implications that it
it sort of reverberated and still does
throughout all these different realms of
human endeavor from our different
artistic
uh you know
experiences that people have can be
colored by this this uh
concept of the unconscious
now the other thing that was interesting
is is is this distinction
you know what what are the parts of the
unconscious and and so there were these
id and ego and superego uh
subdivisions that
you know that that freud for example
would would talk about them and and the
the id was the primary the primal drives
that an infant would have uh or or that
a very young child just warmth and
feeding and then and later the you know
the the sexual or the libidinous aspects
and for freud the later happened very
quickly
that's the controversial thing about him
i think i guess he thought like even
children had sexual desires that they're
like dealing with contending with so
it's the full thing hungry wanting to
eat wanting to poop wanting to have sex
yeah and he was extremely focused on
that on on that aspect
but then there was then there was this
the superego which brought on these
later sort of moralistic
uh
uh sort of codes of conduct and and that
of course was very often in intention
but all this could play out
subconsciously and then the ego
this third aspect was mediating and for
its conception mediated this
tension between the different uh parts
now i think that's interesting uh i will
say that
in some ways
it's maybe unnecessary
from the perspective of modern
neuroscience to
divide things up that way from the you
know the moralistic
drives and the the primal
uh gratification drives
in some ways they're all drives and
maybe they're even all primal drives you
know the the moralistic drives they're
they're taught and they're taught in
ways that ultimately relate back to
survival and
uh you could even say selfish aspects of
of health and life for the self and
family and
so this is uh i don't i think it's maybe
an artificial distinction the concept of
the unconscious is very valuable and
very interesting
but
these categorizations
uh of id and and superego may not
map onto neurobiology in any particular
way if there's a town hall of competing
drives and desires and their
they
interrelate to each other they involve
different aspects of the of the brain
and the history of the person
and actions and choices come out of the
result of that overall you know shouting
in the town hall so in some sense carl
jung was a step into the direction of
liberating yourself from such harsh
categorizations
do you think
i mean you have uh daniel kahneman with
system one of system two
there's just these very compelling
categorizations of the human mind
that seemed to be
sticky
in our uh
in the super ego no uh in the you know
how we talk about these ideas and so on
yeah do you think those are helpful or
do they get in the way is it some kind
of balance in terms of deeper
understanding of how the mind actually
works you know it's from the from modern
neuroscience uh
whenever we
seem to get closer to
addressing a question like this at the
level of cells
it seems to get farther away and i'll
give you an example of what i mean by
that so one thing i'm doing in my
laboratory and many people are doing is
we are listening in on the activity of
cells neurons in the brain of mice or
rats or fish or monkeys individual cells
individual cells exactly of which there
are you know in our brain many billions
and
when we do and we
try to predict what action will be taken
by an animal
to address this question where does
the choice arise where does the
impetus to make a particular selection
of one action versus another action
where does that start in the brain if
you're recording listening in on the
activity of cells all across the brain
where's the earliest spot you can pick
up
a choice being made
well that's so awesome
yeah at one level you might think how
excited would young have been to see
this or freud or the early you know
psychoanalysts to see where this starts
but it's not so simple because
an emerging theme in very recent
neuroscience literally over the last few
years
is that
things sort of all start together all
across the brain and so you can be
recording from the cortex this rim of
cells at the surface of the brain or you
can be recording deeper in a structure
called the striatum which is a little
older
it's more tightly linked to to action
and then structures called the thalamus
other parts of the brain and if you
record from these these
all sort of
represent the action and the choice
more or less all at about the same time
very close and so it's you can't point
to a particular spot
and say here's where
the choice or the action originates it's
finding the free will neuron
that's relevant to that question nobody
is is close to being able to point to
such a thing well close
is a relative term
and nobody
uh what would i tweet today uh all
generalizations are wrong
[Laughter]
so including this one
you